Ambassador at large for global
criminal justice.
She's joining me now from her
trip to Bangladesh.
Ambassador Van Schaack, welcome
to the program.
>> Thank you.
>> Can I ask you to start with
Syria?
We are getting more and more
complaints that actual illegal
none intervention is hopping.
That bashar al-assad is not
allowing humanitarian access
despite international law.
>> Indeed, the arbitrary
withholding of unitarian aid in
an armed conflict situation can
be a violation of the laws of
war.
And using starvation as a
weapon of war is a criminal
punishable war crime.
Here we have a situation where
it seems as if president Assad
is really limiting the ability
for humanitarian aid in this is
a region that is largely
controlled by rebel groups and
opposition groups, which
suggest that this is by design.
>> And he has complained and
his government has complained
that it's all about sanctions
imposed by the international
community.
But we have been told by U.S.
Government John Kirby just on
Friday that there are
exemptions, and that sanctions
do not limit humanitarian aid,
especially in the
circumstances.
Is that correct ambassador?
>> Indeed.
Sanctions regimes have waivers
within them for the provision
of humanitarian aid.
This would include food,
medical care, as well as in a
crisis situation like we have
here.
But the problem is that with
the period in the security
council, there were three
pathways to provide a to Syria
during the conflict.
Russia vetoed those
resolutions.
Now there's only one route to
provide humanitarian aid.
That route has not been damaged
by the earthquake.
And so in order to force the
provision of military aid, we
would need a new security
council resolution, to create a
new pathway.
The fears that Russia will veto
that again in support of its
client state Syria.
>> So ambassador, this leads me
into the important, the equally
important conversation about
holding Russia accountable for
crimes inside Ukraine.
But if you can't even get
Russia, it is diplomatic
capacity, to allow a
humanitarian aid into Syria,
what help do you have of
holding them accountable for
the direct accusation of war
crimes and crimes against
humanity?
>> Indeed, there are three
pathways adjust as that
operational.
The right of the courts and
Ukraine.
And as you mention, there's
more than 65,000 incidents of
war crimes and other potential
atrocities that have been
registered.
The course their operational,
there are war crimes teams.
International community,
including tonight, states have
been funding the provision of
experts who have come from the
worlds war crime tribunals to
assist the prosecutor general
and this incredible challenge.
Pathway them or two is the
international criminal court,
also currently seized of the
situation, because Ukraine has
consented to the exercise of
jurisdiction.
And finally of European courts
and legal authorities that are
starting investigations working
through a joint investigation
team, sharing information, and
strategies in order to be able
to bring --
one perpetrators come within a
jurisdiction.
This however is the major
challenge.
As perpetrators remain in
Russia, it will be very
difficult for many of these
justice pathways to operate
unless in absentia trials are
allowed.
But none of these efforts
require the consent of Russia,
and so all of these
investigations are moving
forward.
>> So just quickly, will trials
in absentia be allowed?
Is there precedence for that?
>> There is precedent, and one
of the Ukrainian system, they
are allowed, and there have
been some cases.
For example, some cases of
sexual violence and other war
crimes have been brought in
absentia where a defendant was
identified, but they did not
have him in custody.
International criminal court
however cannot exercise
jurisdiction in absentia.
All it can do is issue an
arrest warrant, and then
ultimately confirm charges
against individual.
But it cannot move forward
without the custody of the
accused.
>> Can I ask you about the
various pathways, as you
mentioned, they just seem to be,
I'm not quite as a hodgepodge,
but an alphabet soup of
different jurisdictions from
the Ukraine to the
international criminal court,
to Europe, et cetera.
How does that help or
complicate the efforts to
streamline the pursuit of
justice?
>> And the, you often get asked
if this is a chaotic situation.
But what I preferred is
decentralized.
There are a number of different
nodes where justice is
happening.
But European authorities are
increasingly united and
coordinated amongst themselves
under the umbrella of the euro
just genocide network, but also
this joint investigative team
that many European states have
joined, that includes the
prosecutor of the international
criminal court.
And so while there are a number
of efforts happening around the
world, they are increasingly
coordinated and talking amongst
themselves, sharing information,
sharing potential evidence, all
in the insist of justice.
>> What should people in
Ukraine expect.
What are the realistic
expectations.
We've talked about tens of
thousands of allegations, of
crimes, we talked about all of
the groups that have been
funded and really seem to want
to, including Ukrainian human
rights and other groups inside
the country there.
And yet, we know, I guess, from
president, that these processes
take a very long time.
What should people who have
lost their family members or
who have been violently
attacked, sexually attacks,
what should they expect
realistically?
>> They should expect that the
international community
delivers justice wherever it
can be found.
This will involve cases in
Ukrainian courts, and the
prosecutor general will have
the unenviable task of sifting
through those 65 incidents and
determining which one there is
significant evidence to prove,
which one defendant is
available, identifiable, and
whether or not he can work at
the chain of command to reach
more senior figures who may
have been the architect of
violence.
They should also expect
international community to
support the international
criminal court, which is
exercising jurisdiction.
The court has essentially
global jurisdiction, a number
of open investigations in other
wartime contrast of the
situations, and so it needs the
assistance of the international
community.
A number of states have now
personnel, provide additional
voluntary contributions, et
cetera, to all of the justice
efforts.
And so this is, as you
mentioned, a daunting task.
It's an intergenerational
challenge.
But there are no statutes of
limitations or war crimes and
other atrocities, and that we
can be bringing cases for the
next decade.
There are still some cases
being brought against living
not, sees one of the last cases
that Germany brought was
against a very other the
secretary who had been part of
the holocaust and so we will be
prosecuting these cases for
many many years to come.
>> What's important put it in
that kind of historical and
time line context.
But I want to ask you about,
the United States is obviously,
and through your officers,
prominent in the attempt to get
a justice, but you are not
members of the icc.
What are the limits of what the
U.S. Can actually do?
>> I did, we have not ratified
the treaty, the international
criminal court, but over the
years they have been many ways
that we've been able to support
the work of the court.
This includes information
sharing with the prosecutor,
includes issues of witness
protection, and we have helped
to deliver two suspects to the
Hague.
One who showed up at our
embassy in Kigali, Rwanda,
asking to be brought The Hague,
and who was found essentially
fleeing and central Africa.
Both of those defendants have
now gone before the court.
>> That's okay.
They've gone before the court,
I guess the big question for
many Ukrainians and many people
watching is, will Putin ever be
charged.
Have you ever been able to
establish a change a command
responsibility, and if he is,
either publicly or sequel
indicted, will he ever, is
there a very realistic chance
but he might be brought before
a court?
I go back to Milosevic, lots of
mission bosnia, who we followed
the war crimes court against
him at The Hague, and yeah, he
was taken, but he was arrested
inside by his own people.
And then handed over.
What do you think in our show
today?
>> I don't think slobodan
Milosevic ever thought he would
see this type of courtroom.
He was obviously proven wrong.
This will take time, and there
may be a political
transformation within Russia,
such that he is no longer in
power.
This may involve finding
jurisdiction over lower level
individuals first.
We've seen a fair amount of
schism's happening within the
defense infrastructure of
Russia, very generous being
moved around as a strategic
blender of this war becomes
more and more apparent.
And then Russia fails to
perform on the battlefield, and
it's performing quite poorly,
and it's been associated with
atrocities.
Literally everywhere Russia's
forces have been deployed.
And some of these individuals
may either be tossed out of the
country, or they may decide to
leave on their own.
Or risk falling out of a window
for example, as we have seen.
So eventually courts will get
jurisdiction over these
perpetrators, and your mention
of command responsibility is
important because prosecutions
can be brought against the
direct perpetrators, but also
against individuals on the
training command to newer
should've known that their
subordinates were committing
abuses or failed to take the
necessary steps to either
prevent those abuses, over to
prosecute those individuals
after the fact.
So Putin could be prosecuted as
a direct perpetrator for
ordering these offenses, or
under the statute of command
responsibility.
>> And let's go to where you
are right now.
You're at cox's bizarre, it
will not refugee camp, more
recently it has all of the
refugees from Myanmar who also
accused the junta of terrible
war crimes.
And want justice.
You have said that you would
not want Ukraine to cycle the
energy and oxygen out of the
accountability discussion.
What is happening to bring
accountability for the Myanmar
refugees.
>> One of the reason I'm here
is to deliver remember about the genocide
experience at
the hands of the Myanmar
military.
>> Today with survivors and
weather advocates.
Every single one of them spoke
about the importance of
justice.
There are as in Ukraine, it
multiple different pathways to
justice.
There is a case of an open and
the international criminal
court.
Because Bangladesh is a member
of that statute.
And so crime so deportation
that involve the crossing
international border can be
right before the international
criminal court.
Also the Gambia which is a west
African nation has broad suit
against Myanmar for state
responsibility for genocide
under the genocide --
that case is moving forward.
When a woman with who I spoke a
travel to the Hagan order to
support that case.
In addition, we've seen
Argentina, Germany, other
national courts open or
entertain petitions by
complainants, by victims in
order to potentially bring suit
before their own national core
center principles of
extraterritorial jurisdiction.
--
>> The challenge remains the
same.
Custody of the accused.